recent postdocs Aziz in a recent
graduate student at u-dub like Koepke
and my current graduate student Chris
plays now let's see how it works so the
same setup the setup of mapping that I'm
sure it's familiar to all of you
although it's rather different from what
a lot of this workshop has been about we
want to try and find where in the genome
of the genes that affect particular
traits and what we have us usually
genetic magnetic marker data usually
snip data whether from calls from
sequences or from your snip chips and
your trade data and the classic
association test which you're all
familiar with says just look at the
association between the traits and the
allelic types at your snips and as we
heard this morning our various problems
and difficulties with the straight
association test but for me one of the
biggest problems with it is that it
really ignores the structure of our
genomes it really ignores the fact that
our genome descends in blocks over the
generations and quite large flocks if
we're talking generation to generation
there in recent generations and it also
ignores the fact that the actual
functional genes are in blocks or blocks
may be separated by introns and
everything else but they're basically
blocks and there are many many ways to
have many different variants within a
functional gene so that if you do an
association test as well see ya it's
you've got big problems with allelic
heterogeneity so instead I take the view
that we should go back to what we used
to do in pedigrees we're now going to do
it in populations not pedigrees but what
we need to look at isn't association in
the descent of the of the snips and the
descent of the trait and we do that
through looking at so-called identity by
descent which I'm not going to go into
how do we define it but think of it just
as relative to some ancestral population
some time point in the past and we say
that our chunk of DNA is identical by
descent if it's a copy of the same chunk
of DNA in some common ancestor of my
individuals in that population and the
whole idea behind identity by descent
base mapping is rather than I said say
looking at direct association between
the trait and the unique type of the
snip
is to look at the Association in shared
dissent with similarity in phenotype so
that's the basic basic idea yeah whoops
yes okay now we're going to do
model-based inference and we all know
what the model for dissent really should
be if we really wanted to have a quote
true model it should be the ancestral
recombination graph but unfortunately
their ancestral recombination graph
point made by silent Myers this morning
is much too complicated to use for the
sorts of problems I want to use it for
various of people have made valiant
attempts to use it for inference
marycoon er you can see Washington being
one of them and using sequential Markov
approximation to the coalescence Xiao
Jie Zheng has also done some work that's
even expanded it by flip I think at
least an order of magnitude in terms of
the lengths of the segments you can look
at and do inference for but that's far
shorter than the segments I want to look
at because I'm interested in fairly
recent identity by descent over the last
maybe 50 generations maybe going up to
100 generations
I'm therefore interested in segments of
the genome there are millions of base
pairs long and most of the ancestral
combination graph as we know is that
deep history and really that's
irrelevant talk we want to look at
emphasizing a game that what we're
interested in are these long segments of
recent descent the same picture well
same idea presented by it's like
yesterday and actually I always dated to
work by my very first PhD student Kevin
Donnelly who is not the famous Donnelly
it's different Donnelly he did this
thing that I think was great and very
relevant to what we do today showing
what we all knew of course already that
was the probability of identity by
descent at any particular location in
genome decreases exponentially with the
number of meiosis of separation and also
the probability of sharing any genome in
your autosomal genome also decreases
eventually exponentially uh once it gets
going but the length of an identity by
descent segment only decreases as 1 over
the number of meiosis
so these rid guys for example who are
separated by 12
my OCS over here the probability their
identity by descent at any particular
point in the genome prior probability
before we look at any data of course is
five and ten thousand there's a
reasonable probability that they do have
some segments of their autosomal genome
identical by descent and the expected
length of that segments is eight and a
half million base pairs the effect is
more extreme as I go to more remote
relatives individuals that have blue
guys separated by 20 meiosis there
there's only a chance at two and a
million at any point in the genome that
they'll share identity by descent and
interestingly only one in a thousand
such pairs will share any of their
autosomal like you know identity by
descent so I think that this really
speaks against this idea of detecting
relatedness of remote relatives you're
not detecting relatedness you because if
you're talking about this sort of level
because most of the people who are
related at that level won't share any of
their autosomal genome identical by
descent but a few pairs will and again
if they are your game you're talking
about lengths of the order of millions
of base pairs so these segments of
identity by descent are rare but not
shortest Kevin put it just over 30 years
ago and it's the human genome come on
what okay human genome that is that is
short yeah miss in these term human
genome is short the next source all
preliminary points I want to make it
says vine only identity by descent I
know everything I need to know whether
I'm talking about a pedigree or a
population given so here's a little
example but this is a little pedigree
where it's me and my two cousins from my
granddad we shared particular locus this
red one identical by descent and my
cousin C actually shares his pattern or
one identical by descent from his dad's
locus I don't need to know that if I'm
interested in analyzing data just on me
and my two cousins all I need to know is
that little graph at the top but I have
a blue and a red one I had a red one
with my cousin Cu she has the pink one
with his brother D and if I write them
on to write down the probability for
example that C is a slip maybe this guy
is homozygous that and I and D
heterozygous then we immediately look at
that graph and say okay immediately what
have I got the red one pink ones have
got a bill delay the other two have got
to be little B I've got two A's and two
beers probability frequency of a squared
frequency of B squared and I'm done and
I can equally if I have some model for
some quantitative trait equally well
almost equally easily write down the
probability of the trait data that I see
and compute that probability is simply
by summing up over the potential allelic
types to that to that local haplotype on
you know attributes of the to the trait
so the trait data depends on the allelic
types of the two DNA chunks that you
carry so that's great that's a guy we
want to go for agrees we just don't
think about populations in a population
it might very well be that my marker
data suggests or somebody tells me that
my uncle by marriage of my grandad
they're actually related as well and
then actually in this locus the pink one
and the red one are also identical by
descent and this writing down the
probabilities if they're even easier
because all it does is collapse the
graph so the red one of the pink one are
now the same thing see has two copies of
the now red one if I want to write down
this same probability also I have I have
I have that I have that I have now have
one A two B's one a and two B's and I'm
done but in order to do that I need some
population potent model I need some
population probability models to combine
these that gives me some probability of
bringing the case when they're not
identical in the place when they are
identical so we're going to need we're
going to need to make inferences of IBD
from our snip data but we're also going
to need models that give us prior
probabilities of those things now ten
this IBD based mappings game this is
sort of what sort of set up to us just
to start things off can this IBD based
mapping work and with Ferren and mainly
with sharon our browning a couple of
years ago we did a simple study just to
say well Kenny is there enough power and
so what she did with the simulation
study is simulating an evolutionary
population which she then Sochi
simulated base population with selection
and recombination and then from that
base population ran it down to twenty
five generations in this example we did
various examples and we were measuring
our identity by descent which we assumed
we could observe
relative to that twenty five generation
base and she was basically simulating a
gene region of two hundred kilobases
pairs and these are alternating blocks
of one KB and the central KB you could
think of these as a very artificial five
exons of a gene that's where the causal
slips are and have marker search she
took one the most informative one that
grows in each of these one killer base
pair blocks so we've got a hundred nice
model six so we didn't want to do down
association I think what Association
mapping to do as well as it could do and
then and then we had causal variants
maruzen our simulation though in those
five central blocks typically there are
order of magnitude ten it didn't depend
too much as total in the population
variance total in those five central
blocks and our realizations and ended
and we didn't want we wanted to have a
signal but we didn't want it to be so
strong that you couldn't tell any that
so we made it so that individuals with
at least one causal variant became cases
rather than controls with probability
ten percent so not at source so
something we can actually detect because
otherwise there won't be any point
during the study but not something that
was so extreme that somebody could say
well you're just looking at a quote and
Demian trait or simple trade and we did
our standard association test of course
in the identity by descent based tests
again we were looking at [ __ ] identity
by descent so we were looking at shared
IBD in k-space pairs as compared with
other pairs case non case pairs on one
case non case bears in any real study of
course the tends to be a difference in
relatedness between your cases and your
controls for just a future population
heterogeneity
basically and so we just did for that by
adjusting for the genome-wide average in
the group
but then we did permutation testing to
give us our significance so we did the
standard things and this is just one set
of our results and the realtor once you
see them they're not at all surprising
when selection is fairly weak you have
roughly the same number of total
variants but the frequencies of those
variants are higher so the total
frequency of haplotypes tearing at least
one causal variant was of the order of
five percent up to thirteen percent and
so so the cases that tended to be some
snip with which you had a very strong
association between the trait and that
market snip so Association mapping did
pretty well even in a very small study
and did rather better than the IBD test
in fact substantially better than the
IBD base test but as selection got
stronger so your separate variants and
even your total frequency of your
variants got quite a lot lower then they
tended not to be an association of your
trait with anyone with any one of your
market snips you needed larger studies
of course that you can get some
reasonable power that's that you could
compare and the IBD based test was
winning out so that's that's published a
couple of years ago now it's quite old
but it does show that idd based mapping
can work and can do things in
populations where you have a Lili
Quechua genera T and we're doing okay go
faster I guess okay so something I was
interested even before that work ended
with Sharon but now it became much more
interested in is I don't just want to
look at pairwise IBD but I dub between
pairs of chromosomes or even between
pairs of individuals I want to look
samples from my population and look at
the joint IBD structure like those
little graphs with me and my two cousins
and hopefully even larger graphs so we
have these what we call like the
identity by descent for us which are
show for my sample in the individuals
each one of course having two DNA knows
this particular locus which ones they're
sharing with which other individuals in
the population and these likely be just
the ones who are sharing out of my
sample there might be a lot of other
individuals so at this particular
location don't share anything at one
point I want to make
is that in fact paralyzed sharing even
even intrinsically doesn't give you all
the information so this structure is
very different structure here we have
three individuals who share one IBD note
here you have three individuals who each
share one with the other individual if
you just look at your data pairwise
there's no difference between those
situations but they obviously have very
different structures and could have very
different effects in terms of their
traded and spending on the architecture
of the trait very different implication
for the trait and the other thing to
point out is that your data could be
just affected another fake tits in your
population but on the whole you do a lot
better if you have some sort of
quantitative trait or at least ranked
values of traits and what you gain your
looking for is an association between
sharing genome that is identity by
descent and similarity of trait values
okay what's next
okay well before we can do any of that
okay everything I've done so far says
okay assume that I can see this identity
by descent the first thing we got to do
is to find the identity by descent and
again it's 6 or basically mentioned how
you do this we want to do a model based
inference and again this comes this came
a consignment store again this morning
if you do a model-based inference of
probability based inference you have
measures of uncertainty and also it
allows you to give multiple realizations
from that posterior probability
distribution given the snip data so so
yeah and then you can use those multiple
realizations in analyzing the trait I
want multiple imputations
jointly across the genome of chromosome
a genome segment whatever you like and
of course we want to combine the
information from snips across the genome
each snippers own gives almost no
information about identity by descent
but because it comes in these larger
segments with more and larger segment
segments of millions of base pairs in a
pair of chromosomes at least then we can
detect them simply by having a very
simple model where if their ID
by the scent they should be of the same
allelic type and if they're not
identical by descent in some sense
they're quote independent allelic types
so we're going to need two things a
model for the process of identity by
descent along the chromosome and I'll
show you a couple of models and more
importantly which I'm not going to talk
so much about but it turns out to be the
much more critical part in actually
getting things to work well is immortal
for your snip data given the underlying
identity by the center so a very simple
model for the identity by descent and
inferring identity by descent which in
which all our current model reason I'm
showing you is that all our current
models are basically generalizations of
this Ann Lewis Lloyd mega
student of mine back in night 2003 she
was just comparing identity by scent
between the pair of gametes within an
individual by the way I tend to call
them gametes because haplotypes and
chromosomes and all those words have so
many other connotations the gametes are
haploid genomes of my individuals and
Alan Pig ewis okay to gametes
they just had segments where they're not
identical by descent and then small not
to be smaller segments where they are
identical sent not they are so it's just
a two-state process you would have very
simple two parameter Markov model that's
where the marginal probability the
point-wise probability of being
identical by descent is some beta the
change rate of global change rate
changes into IBD rare-earth and changes
out of IBD the IBD segments are shorter
but the global rate that scales things
is just this my single parameter alpha
and of course this is an approximation
identity by descent is not Markov and
expected that lengths depends on the
number of my LC still the common
ancestor we're talking about and there
may be multiple common ancestors but
this is certainly a good enough model
for as a prior and then the MA the model
that she used is the one we just said if
they're identical by the sense they
should be the same allelic type here and
here if they're not identical by descent
they may or may not be the same allelic
time and actually on all our models we
allow for quote error fuzz of some kind
whether we believe there are errors or
not you should always make that
allowance so that things that are
observed of different allelic type can
still be inferred to be IBD or to be
within an IBD segment and this of course
is a very very simple hmm with just two
latent states so you computer a law you
compute backwards you can get the
probability of IBD at each point at each
point along the genome and more
importantly from my point of view okay
again because we're going to want
realizations you can get joint
realizations of the IBD by computing
forwards and going backwards along the
genome across the chromosome in your
standard hmm tight way okay but now we
want to extend this model to multiple
gametes so we're good to need first
thing we're going to need is simply a
model for the IBD partition of my
gametes at a given point in the genome
and you know well you ones for more than
40 years ago
yay was a beautiful one parameter
distribution for the partition of n
objects into K groups he uses a model
for allelic variation but is equally
good as a model of any sort of partition
with just that one parameter which this
is it's in the for humans theater this
fit may be slightly more familiar to
people who know you and solving formulas
just two different ways of writing the
same thing and we can use this as a
model of a partition of our end gametes
at any point into some number of IBD
groups model for the IBD partition is
this return in terms of genetic
variation theta I want something in
terms of this pairwise probability of
IBD beta but it's very easy to translate
from one to the other because I simply
plug into the formula for two gametes
the probability that they are in the
same partition just turns out to be 1
over 1 plus theta and that's my beta so
I can go from one to the other but no
problem that's nice but now I also need
a model for how this is going to change
a prior model for how my IBD partitions
are going to change as I go along the
chromosome
these are IBD graphs they're fairly
dense ones because they actually came
from a pedigree example originally but
other things just think of them as that
same little graphs showing my individual
abcdefg well what they share with other
individuals for example up there at the
top a bj and G will share that one that
is arbitrarily labeled - as I go along
the chromosome there are going to be
recombination events in the ancestry of
these gametes so for example it might be
a get at the egg recombination and the
ancestry that led to this damage here
that actually smooth this k with this
gammy this or this individual k from
sharing that one not sharing it with
anybody else who happens to be observed
but instead sharing with DG NF so what
it does is simply move this gamete k1
into this this this group here IBD group
here as I go a bit further along the
chromosome I might find that for example
the e thing leading to the zero gamete
of individual J currently being Jerry
share both their gametes identical by
descent but then the might be a
recombination in the ancestry leading to
that particular gamete of J which would
actually move j0 gamete of j out of the
group
so it's gametes move into and out of or
in between groups in that sort of way
and we need a model for that well again
this is familiar to many people here
there's a really neat way to build up
for you and sampling formula known as
the Chinese restaurant process so we've
got a Chinese restaurant with any number
of tables of any size and currently
there are n people in there who happen
to be sick a occupied tables and the new
person comes in and they see a friend
with probability proportional to the
number of people at there at that table
so they join that table with probability
proportional to the number of people
sitting there or they sit down at a new
empty table with a probability
proportional to 1 minus or minus that
probability so a little example here we
just got six gametes three occupied
tables three two on one the new one
comes in sits down with probability
proportional so three video to beta beta
or sits down as an empty table with
probability proportional so one minus
beta and then you just have your new
state right with the new gamete
it's very easy to show that if you're
previously had the urine sampling
formula on in this case six gametes then
your new state is you and sampling
formula on seven games that's all very
well but I want to have unison ooh and
softly formula is my marginal
distribution on a fixed number of n
Gammy's I don't want to keep increasing
number of gametes right and as I say all
the best ideas are simple in a
retrospect but this is a very neat idea
douche as easy on how to do this and
allows any one gamete descent you to
move from one IBD subset to another so
potential changes in IBD now are going
to occur at this sum normalized rate
alpha along the chromosome we don't
worry about that what that is
and as out of each potential change
point we add a new gamete in exactly the
same way we did before he joins the
tables with proportion to the number of
people already there or at a new table
but probability 1 - Peter get my new
state but now I rendered select one of
the n plus 1 gametes in this case 7
gametes to leave of course if the one
who just came in leaves then I haven't
changed anything but if one of the
others leaves then the star gets the
label of the one that's leaving so again
yeah is that the same as having the
Joint Distribution of PI 6 and PI 7 and
the UN Sam under the Chinese restaurant
given the PI sea sky your sample the PI
7 guy and then given the PI 7 guy you've
sampled conditionally after the PI SIG's
guys say you run Chinese restaurant
forward and then backwards to another
plastics guy I think so but you would
probably know better than I do
sometimes if somebody at the same table
leaves and again you haven't changed
anything but if somebody at a different
table leaves and then see what you do is
move this gamete is now part of this
group or in this case this gamete moves
from this group into the other group
because the star gets the label D so
essentially what this does is precisely
what we want it allows us to have
simple while it's probably not a real
mark it's not a it's a prior model for
what's going on in terms of the sorts of
changes in IBD that can happen along the
chromosome
I was going to show you yeah I guess
I'll - I'll show you there's some little
bits of results we've done with just six
camis the problem is again a point made
by Nick I think the number of partitions
goes up hugely so it's very hard to
think about partitions among large
numbers of gametes it's not so hard to
think about six gametes or three
individuals so we've been doing a lot of
test examples on that this is just a
representation of the underlying space
there are 203 states here ordered in
lexicographic ordering from the case
where they're all ided to the case where
none of them I D D and each node
represents a potential partition and the
lines represent the possible transitions
that are can occur under the process I
just described where the color
represents the label of the gamete
that's leaving the one that tans hits
that the one that's changing potentially
changing his IV D partition and the
levels here are just the different
levels by BD 6 5 + 1 4 2 and so on up to
one pair IBD and the color is not
uniquely determined in the case when
it's a pair resolving off but that's one
representation so I show the next one -
yes I feel it this is just a very simple
little example of one where we did our
hmm and again now doing realization that
this was out of a simulated population
this is just a small block of mm snips
over 50 million base pairs and this is
the truth and the other 10-5 on either
side are realizations from the posterior
but one thing I'll point about Howard
here is that the the labeling problem
this is the main reason I wanted to show
this so for example if you look at this
guy up here in the top left the blue guy
at the bottom there he may have become
ided I wonder if I can show this on the
screen he may become IBD because he
actually becomes IBD with the magenta
one as he does there he may change color
simply because other things of karate-do
and that's the labeling you happen to
use there's an arbitrariness in the
labeling that says here we're going to
use
canonical ordering labeling so if
there's only five distinct gametes you
don't get a blue color you don't get a
gamete six you don't get a thing six
there are other ways you can do it where
you can actually say that I will only
allow my gametes to this is actually the
same representation same results but
just with a different representation of
the labeling now only a gamete will only
change color if he does actually change
his IBD but it's not clear that that's
really any easier way to do things
because colors now have no meaning
across realizations across chromosomes
because it'll depend on what happened in
the previous history of which colors
available which table is available for
the new ganic to sit right at one other
point I'll make about this one this is a
area of deliberately a very very high LD
obviously my realizations have trouble
nine out of ten of my realizations had
big trouble with this region right here
the nice things about realizations is
okay got your real real realizations
that maybe don't take LD into account or
not very well but you could've been then
you're going to use these as multiple
imputations in some trait analysis you
can weight them ID LD say down weight
the regions locally that have to have
the high LD in accordance with the local
haplotype frequency as compared to the
frequency that you use to generate them
these these are run raw and then I what
I'm going to do is use use LD
information afterwards to down weight
areas of that drop down right in
inferences that have much lower
probability under correct LD model then
under the one I generated a simple way
to weight them really nice thing about
realizations you can weight things left
right and center but the biggest the
biggest thing out of this game this is
next ones that older but really what we
see here is that there is a labeling
problem and it was a labeling problem
that we run into ran into a pedigrees
when we were doing these sort of things
in pedigrees a few years ago and some
really nice work by high Koepke has
really enables us to do things really
efficiently her height was not my
graduate student he was a student in our
department
or computer science or until I am
because the point about these identity
by descent prances nodes have no natural
meaning they only have meaning through
the things that impinge upon them that
that is that the that these three
individuals share this DNA idd right
that's the if anything it matters and
and when you drew these realizations on
a base pair scale that fairly slowly
changing right so we have ranges of
markers ranges and markers ranges of
base pairs for which it doesn't change
we have different realizations where if
my data are strong we're going to get
the same realizations of the structure
there possibly with the different
labeling as we saw and yeah and
different labelings so so having
software that recognizes when the
structure the ID did rough structure is
the same really can increase the
efficiency of any genetic analysis you
do subsequent because you only have to
do it once for each different structures
that you have and then apply that
structure wherever you meet it so it's
really yeah it's it really made life
much much easier and what it does is
also allow us to have trait models if we
want to that actually depend not just on
the IVD at a single locus the classic
simple ones but allow on the joint
pattern of IBD that we have for a
different website because we had a gank
because we had these realizations of
this joint ided across the chromosome
okay okay I'm doing fine
well that went fairly fast okay
so that's fine
we started with Ann Lewis Lloyd Nagar
doing two gametes we then did a lot of
work for for Janice that I haven't
talked about pairs of individuals there
more recently we've been looking at six
counties where you can still run the hmm
but of course we want to look at large
numbers of gametes and each in a large
population it may be the ditch component
graph is not that is not that large so
the actual IBD graph that at any locus
is not that the components are not that
large but we want to be able to do the
inference for a much larger number of
gametes and again the problem as well as
you simply can't do the hmm the number
of partitions is simply huge and they've
been various M C and C approaches that I
won't talk about Saudis any again has
done a full Bayesian M C and C under
under sensually this Chinese restaurant
process model which handles up to forty
gametes and can do things basically
across a chromosome and that section
right now impressin journal of
computational biology and chris glaze
now my current students has been trying
very hard to get a particle filter MCMC
approach to work and it and it sort of
works for this it's hard it's a hard
problem when you have these very large
state spaces but an early approach the
studio chris glaze nur has been working
really well and i'll show you the
results on that so basically what he
does is like Matthew Stephens product of
proximate conditional lapak likelihood
in some sense building the IBD state
across the promess ohm adding diploid
individuals successively to the IBD
state sampling them by what you've
already as computing forward and
sampling back by what you've already
inferred so to take the very first steps
of it with just three individuals and
then it builds from there you might take
the first two individuals and infer the
identity by descent between them
conditional on their marker data
come on
conditional on their market data a and
being conditional on the market date on
a and B then you take a third individual
and infer the identity by descent state
between B and C given what you have
constrained already between a and B but
given the data not on a B and C but only
on B and C that's where the
approximation comes in and then having
done that you do the third leg of the
triangle and infer the identity by
descent state between a individual a and
individual C Redeemer pairs of
individuals at each stage so that just
15 states about identity among therefore
Gami it's quite easy to do conditional
on what you've already inferred between
a and B in between B and C and
conditional this time on the data on a
and the data on C and then you can prove
that you can build up from there
basically only ever considering
triangles as three sets of three
individuals at time and it will give you
it gives you your realizations so one
way or another
using these Markov models for the latent
IBD having marker data that is dependent
on the latent IBD state we do have these
methods for realizing this identity by
the sense among individuals that you
don't know to be related and we wanted
to see how that would work in a fairly
classic pedigree context but written but
not knowing the pedigree so here's a
pedigree when I do the analysis I'm not
going to use this pedigree right great
that very clear but to simulate the data
we had a pedigree and in this particular
one we actually had it and this came
from a real pedigree strategy originally
but that's sort of by the way we had a
founder up here who had a an allele who
had a fairly strong positive effect on a
quantitative trait that allele
segregated down to these three families
at the bottom and then we simulated snip
data out so then we simulated treat data
on these green yellow guys down at the
bottom and then we simulated snip data
on the chromosome conditional on the
inheritance of that the trait locus and
simulated snip data across the
chromosome so we have snip marker data
on these yellow green guys down the
bottom and then we throw away the
pedigree but we had but we could infer
the IBD
and a lot score is just a function of
the IBD you don't need the pig we tend
to think of the classical English let's
go at something you compute on a
pedigree it's actually a function of the
IBD not apathetically Oh
given the IBD the 10-degree is
irrelevant saying this we saw on that
very first graph and the black line here
and again we've simulated a trait that
would give us a fairly strong signal but
so but the black line here is what the
Lord score we would get across the
chromosome this is the true trait
location if we could observe that true
IBD in our individuals the blue dotted
line is what we got if we simply through
the genotypic data on those green guys
down the bottom I think is about 30 of
them yeah on these guys just through the
true genius if ik genotypic data unfazed
at the IBD inference and then from the
IBD influence estimated the LOD score
and you see we do pretty well but we
don't really get everything we did
everything we would like to and we don't
get quite as strong a signal but if we
have phased data on those individuals
down the bottom
we essentially recover the true odds got
the LOD score given the true IBD some
people have said well so that it's all
coming from these close relatives down
the bottom son you can obviously infer
the IBD very well between the close
relatives in fact that's not true if you
look at the LOD score just given the
little pedigrees down the bottom you get
a tiny tiny hump there you don't get
anything like the logs going and sing
there so it's so yeah I think that's the
story and I guess the conclusion is that
we really can base our genetic analysis
in the modern world we can base our
genetic now sits on inferred IBD because
we can get the really these realizations
of the IBD given our snip data and
whether you're talking about pedigrees
or populations the overall your test
statistics whether it's a association
test Association an identity test or
let's go on your IBD based test
statistics they're all just functions of
the IBD modeling the sense is that you
hortence because but again the details
of the model turn out to not matter very
much but the fact that our DNA comes in
segments the human genomes is important
it is very important to be flexible in
your models and I've come to think that
assuming a pedigree structure those big
ancestral pedigrees we used to love so
much you don't know that right and it's
very inflexible it's far too inflexible
when it from any of these analyses
always assume error in your market data
we actually I didn't go into it but
actually we do allow a slight
generalization on our Chinese restaurant
process because sometimes there are
events in the ancestry of chromosomes
but move more than one gamete from an
IBD group to another group and that's it
and there there are the references and
again I'd like to acknowledge Sharon
Browning or captain hood is the IBD work
and Louise Lloyd and Egger who did the
original hmm for this idd inference and
Xiao Jie Zheng who's been doing this
more recent IBD based inference and
Chris glaze and that hasn't published
this work yet he's busy writing up his
thesis but he was on an earlier paper
where we were dealing with pairs of
individuals
yeah but it turns out the prior doesn't
matter much the deleted the data are so
strong in inferring these are IBD
segments particularly when you start to
combine you to cross more Oldham pairs
of individuals that so long as I have a
reasonable value of Peter and a sensible
value of alpha and the model the time
isn't exactly right it works I'll get
the same IVD saying that's young songs
finding the same thing right
we used to worry much more about that
model but yes I mean I yeah yeah and
knowing the degree of relatedness you
know these guys that they pleated these
more remote levels of religious they may
or may not share anything IBD anyhow so
just knowing some sort of expected level
of relatedness isn't isn't really hoping
a very good question no you didn't miss
this act was something I swept under the
rug yeah we actually do a way of
erection or better approximations now
but we don't exponentiate the continuous
continuous good I said that so that's
why I was interested particular and
Steve's talk but though I'm not going to
try and do anything nearly as
complicated as Steve because Yale we
approximate it by a discreet snip to
snip transition which was which is
pretty accurate with our new
approximations so the nice thing about
the particle filter and one reason why
we had big hopes for the particle filter
sorry I've lost it Chris closeness
during the partner Monte Carlo particle
filter approach and there he is using
the continuous process to generate
things server so that's why we hoped the
particle Volta was going to do good
things for us because we hoped it was
then going to be enables us to use an
actual genuine continuous underlying
wrong
yes well so beta is the sort of pairwise
kinship in the population and it depends
on how deep you want to go in most of
our examples sorry I'm losing things
again yeah in the simulated population
we actually ended up relative to 200
generations ago which was probably
trying to push things too far back with
a pairwise kinship of 0.05 yes most of
the time the prior is that most of the
time you're going to be in a state of no
IBD with this which we said wasn't
particularly much of on this chromosome
second son I think under these
particular parameter values about half
the time you're in the state of no IBD
in the six counties the true state the
true state well recent approximation
allows up to two switches between pair
of snips but guess
that's just computation but you but
you're right that's thing you can have
more you get more changes as you get
more out so that's something we're
probably going to have oh wait sorry
that the game ncnc
showers it's got this very neat MCMC and
again he is using the continuous
continuous process in his